hey guys it is Wednesday I'm just I'm
not Jeff and we're here to tell you
about the gaming news things that happen
to this first up those promised
enhancements for the Xbox one X version
of The Witcher 3 have been announced and
it sounds like girls will be looking
better than ever
well at least as good as he does on PC
celebrate red has revealed that the
witcher 3 will run at 4k on xbox one act
but it's currently unclear if that's
going to be native 4k deadly Jakob
cutter Zuba said there will also be
numerous visual tweaks including
higher-quality shadows ambient collision
and texture filtering as well as higher
resolution textures and an all-around
performance boost if you're feeling like
that's kind of vague you're not alone
what we do know is those without 4k
displays will be able to take advantage
of super sampling to get a better
picture that's when the game renders at
a greater resolution and then shrinks it
down and complete with extra pixel
fidelity so kind of like the opposite of
what the Xbox one is used to it sounds
like EA is still holding back from
completely supporting the Nintendo
switch according to a new report from
The Wall Street Journal a finance chief
Blake Juergen sin' told the Wall Street
Journal that EA is waiting until the
switch has been on the market for a full
year before deciding whether to release
more games for it EA already released
FIFA 18 for the switch in late September
your Linson added that it's too soon for
EA to judge the success of FIFA 18 on
the device and wants to quote fully
understand what the demand is for switch
before committing more resources to
making more games for it basically they
want to see how much profit they make on
FIFA 18s microtransactions first if
you're a big loser like me with three
max level destiny two characters then
you'll be pleased to hear that the
upcoming DLC curse of Cyrus is gonna
raise the level cap game or destiny to
play said level cap hike applies to both
the standard player level and power
levels according to activision and
Bungie Eurogamer has reported that the
new level cap is 25 raised from 20 and
the new power cap is 330 up from 300 of
course through the use of gear mods you
can raise that overall number by 5 so
presumably in 335 is the new magic
number a new ghost named Segura is being
introduced who will be voiced by Marina
back
which means destiny 2 is getting
seriously close to hiring every Firefly
11 to do voice work for the game Bungie
also revealed that the ps4 exclusive
crucible map coming in customer Cyrus is
called worm Haven and is set in Titans
new Pacific ecology area per service
Cyrus is due out on December 5th that is
everything we've got for you today do
let us know what you thought about
today's stories in that comment box and
we didn't mention it in today's show but
there are a bunch of PS + + games with
both games that you can pick up right
now so for you well well great yeah if
you have the subscription if you want to
know what all those are you can check it
out on the site on our youtube channel
but uh anymore
and it sounds like girls will be looking
better than ever at least and girls will
be looking better than ever
well at least I get as good as he does
on PC I'm gonna cut that